well now that the oral arguments are
over what happens next Robert Ray's a
member of trumps legal team he joins us
now Robert I'm so tired of covering this
I get Sippel oh nice name pronunciation
wrong how good is that where do we go
from here
I think that we are in the process of
counting votes to see whether or not
there will be witnesses and I imagine
for many senators how the questioning
goes and the answers that are given over
the next two days may have some bearing
it's obviously their judgment to make
and that will we'll know the answer but
presumably on Friday probably after a
very very long day of debate relative to
that question now Robert there was a lot
of jawboning about the fact that Pat
decided to yield back a lot of his time
like CNN and MSNBC were said well we
expect him to speak for an hour and a
half two hours but I thought it was
really quite quite smart for him to you
know what else we gonna say it's it's
basically so obvious that we're gonna
give you the luxury of time back which I
think a lot of these senators probably
really liked
I think they appreciated it I think we
also did what we promised we would do at
the outset look the the bottom line is
you have recognized for some time we
don't have trials just as sort of roving
fact gatherers to decide anything under
the Sun the task at hand is to have a
trial to determine whether or not it's
appropriate to remove the president from
office period end of story once you've
made your argument with regard to that
question which is after all the only
question to be decided I think it's time
to sit down and let the senators you
know and put your faith and trust in
them as Pat Cipollone he said at the end
and respect and abide by their wisdom
their the people's elected
representatives in this body and that's
what their that's what they're elected
to do and I thought it was it was really
refreshing that after Nadler basically
accusing the Senate of being
co-conspirators with Trump and in civil
comes along and says why don't we all
start to work together what is one of
the Republicans that Democrats start
working together for the common good do
the things that you were sent here to do
that was actually really inspiring I
thought and I think people who aren't
really political watch that they
probably saying to themselves yeah that
sounds pretty good
sure it does and I will say also you
know in connection with your panel this
very question by the way is not in a
vacuum
during the Andrew Johnson impeachment
since it was very close to the end of
Andrew Johnson's unexpired term that
occurred as the result of the
assassination of President Lincoln
they clearly and intently focused on the
question why would we want to remove a
president from office when there's an
election coming up and go and as a
result of that Ulysses Grant was elected
president so don't tell me that the we
got to get out but I appreciate you
coming on tonight get some rest